it's been a crazy short season i didn't
know how short 60 would feel we're all
used to 162 actually more than that more
like 180 game season you count the 30
games in spring training
so 60
man it feels like hey we should be here
tomorrow but unfortunately we won't
jordan lyles set to go he's had two
pretty decent games against the astros
in houston two of his best starts
he strikes out springer on three pitches
run away that's a nice start to this
game with a breaking ball really fooled
springer jose altuve the batter hitting
216.
and altuve drives one deep to left field
all the way back and that ball's gone
wow off the facade of the second deck
jose altuve with his second home run of
this series and his fifth of the year
gets the astros on board one to nothing
little man pops so now to the bottom of
the first inning and we look forward to
seeing shinsu chew the rangers
the chew family
excited to hear their dad's name he
comes to the plate designated hitter
today and this is this is pretty special
thomas take a look at the the lineup
he's leading off today as a dh but he'll
have just this one at back let's see
second most lead off home runs in
rangers history
and he bunts third base side tough play
for bregman the throw
two tumbles over first base
with a butt single and
did he give every single thing he had on
that one
i think she wants to stay in the game
but
he really took a tumble
he can't do it chu comes over to the
ranger dugout
and he is hugged by his teammates after
his final at that of the season
there's a swing and a miss and diaz
strikes out one away here in the second
the pitch the swung that i missed
big strikeout there for liles it's the
second out of the unit his third
strikeout of the game runners everywhere
guerrielle
reddick
they're not going to be able to advance
on this one a fly ball to straight away
center field and tavares tucks it away
2-2
swing and a miss got him on a curveball
and chase de young has his first
strikeout two outs
the 2-2
and this one ripped into left field
that's a base hit boy gallow had a huge
jump off second he scores easily
huff drags in his fourth run of the year
and this game is tied
[Applause]
strikeout for de young gives up a run in
the inning on a hit and a hit batter 1-1
game
runner on the go and brantley with a
base hit into center field michael
brantley at 300 for the season with that
base hit and the astros have runners on
first and third two and four in those
six games here gregman tries to check
but he goes around
on this slider down
and he'll strike out
ground ball chopped towards short taheda
has a short hop only has the play to
first scoop by guzman but the astros
retake the lead as altuve scores
it is now 2-1 as jose altuve crosses the
plate on the rbi fielder's choice
i led miss died
in his third inning of work now has a
lead once again
that's a called third strike chase the
young has struck out three of the last
four batters he has faced as he strikes
out anderson to haida
chase to young a one two three inning
with two strikeouts he has struck out
four of the last six batters the young
with a 2-1 lead
and uh correa drills one left center
field deep back goes
tavares and that ball's gone into the
astros bullpen carlos correa home run
number five as he
hits one deep to left center field to
give the astros a three to one lead
the young picks up another strikeout
five strikeouts
of the last six outs
this one through the vacated right side
of the infield gallow was on the move
and solac
takes advantage of the gaping hole on
that right side and now the rangers have
them on the corners
wanna goes from first odor hits this
ball hard deep out to ray
[Applause]
right off the head
a three-run homer for odor his ninth of
the year and now he has the rangers in
front
and he pulls the string a little
swinging a miss on guzman as he gets him
for strikeout number six as a long
inning for chase de young he turns it
over to nevaldo rodriguez with the bases
loaded
3-1 pitch
and this one up the middle that's a base
hit
huff is in
tahedah is in a two-run single for
tavares
and the rangers lead 6-3
curiel giving him a battle though the
2-2 pitch and this one out to right
field caught out there on a slide
by gallow and the inning is over well
that's why when you talk about joey
gallo you talk about a legitimate
candidate to win a gold club door had
the three-run homer in the fourth inning
his ninth of the year he now leads his
team with 29 rbis
depend a lot on where you bat in an
order this ball hit well deep out to
right center gone
and odor now leads the team at home runs
as well his 10th of the year
seven three rangers seven home runs 20
rbis in the month of september yeah
yeah that's encouraging to hear too is
tavares slays down a bunt third base
side and gets himself a hit
oh he's going to third and the throw
down to third base goes into left field
and he'll be able to trot home
well the speed of leote tavares hits
another run and hello
[Applause]
that ball's drilled left center field
and gone oled miss diaz ends his 2020
regular season campaign with a home run
number three on the year
bregman
pops this one up i know where i'm going
right now though
door
tucks it away and this one is over
and the rangers win the final game of
the season they won the first game one
nothing this year from the rockies and
they wrap up this bizarre 2020 season
with an 8-4 win and a three-game winning
streak over the houston astros